und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend israel und das schicksal seines
premiers sind heute abend dann die
spitze der nachrichten gesprungen die
politische landschaft dort war sowieso
schon aufgewühlt zwei wahlen in weniger
als einem halben jahr und immer noch
keine neue regierung und eine dritte
wahl drohte und dann schlug heute noch
der blitz ein
israels generalstaatsanwalt erhebt
anklage gegen den amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten netanjahu
es geht um hunderttausende euro und
politische deals aus unlauteren motiven
tagelang haben netanjahus anwälte den
staatsanwälten hinter verschlossenen
türen
ihre gegenargumente vorgetragen aber die
haben nicht gezogen noch nie in der
geschichte des staates israel gab es so
eine lage nicola albrecht ist unsere
korrespondentin dort nichts wurde wohl
in israel mit mehr spannung erwartet als
diese entscheidung premierminister
netanjahu wird angeklagt und das in
gleich drei fällen betrug und untreue
sowie bestechlichkeit verkündet israels
generalstaatsanwalt avishai mandl blick
am abend
benjamin netanjahu ist ein geschätzter
mann und premierminister
ich hatte selbst die ehre mit ihm zu
arbeiten und habe diese entscheidung mit
schwerem herzen aber auch voller
juristischer überzeugung getroffen
netanjahus fall geht es um
machtmissbrauch beeinflussung der medien
zu seinen gunsten
der vorwurf er habe einem unternehmen
rechtliche und wirtschaftliche vorteile
in millionenhöhe verschafft und im
gegenzug habe eine zum konzern gehörende
in israel populäre nachrichtenplattform
positiv über ihn berichtet zudem geht es
um zweifelhafte luxus geschenke für
100000 euro
mit anja bestreitet seit langem die
vorwürfe spricht von verschwörung und
hexenjagd
obwohl es sich um einen rein
juristischen vorgang in einem
rechtsstaat handelt rücktritt kommt für
ihn nicht in frage
stattdessen geht er in die offensive man
muss blind sein um nicht zu sehen dass
etwas schlechtes bei der polizei und dem
büro der staatsanwaltschaft vor sich
geht heute abend zeigt sich das ist ein
klarer putschversuch gegen mich als
premierminister
könig baby so nennen sie netanjahu in
israel seine freunde und seine gegner
gleichermaßen
und so stehen sie heute abend auch vor
seinem wohnhaus in jerusalem
die einen wollen ihn vom thron stürzen
die anderen bekunden ihre solidarität
wir rufen nun alle konservativen auf
gegen dieses unrecht gegen diesen
putschversuch zu demonstrieren
politisch wird es nun tatsächlich eng
für netanjahu
er kämpft nicht nur gegen die justiz
sondern auch um sein überleben als
premierminister nikola wir haben heute
abend gelernt es gibt kein gesetz das
den ministerpräsidenten zwingt wegen
einer anklage zurück zu treten wird er
sich jetzt halten können nun hinter hat
in israel noch einen zweiten spitznamen
und der heißt der magier
aber netanjahu zauberkräfte schwinden
derzeit rasant denn es geht hier um
knallharte machtpolitik und internet hat
es innerhalb eines jahres bei zwei
parlamentswahlen nicht geschafft eine
regierung zu bilden
jetzt steuert das land auf eine dritte
wahl zu und er hat politische gegner
nicht nur in der opposition sondern auch
in den eigenen reihen und die stehen
möglicherweise jetzt in den startlöchern
um die palastrevolte zu starten und sich
das durch die justiz legitimieren zu
lassen
nun ist ja israel weg einer komfortablen
lage sondern in einem viel fronten
konflikt mit syrien iran hamas hisbollah
und so weiter da braucht es stabilität
hilft oder schadet das nicht an
in dieser lage nun bislang hat es
netanya immer geschafft durch sein image
durch sein charisma und durch seine
rhetorik als derjenige hervorzugehen der
die sicherheit israels als einziger
gewährleisten kann und auch in den
letzten zwei wochen hat er versucht
dieses image noch einmal zu bekräftigen
er hat einen kurz krieg mit gaza geführt
er hat militärschläge gegen syrien
ausführen lassen
doch der große applaus dafür ist in den
letzten tagen schlicht und ergreifend
ausgeblieben und wie gesagt seine gegner
stehen den startlöchern und zwar nicht
nur in der opposition sondern auch in
den eigenen reihen und tanja aus image
gerät deutlich ins wanken
die geschichte ist noch nicht zu ende
offenbar dankeschön nicola und damit
nach deutschland und zu einem
schmerzhaften problem wichtige
medikamente werden mangelware
medikamente auf die man nicht warten
kann von krebsmitteln bis zu
alltäglichen schmerztabletten wäre der
sache auf den grund geht stellt fest das
problem hat sich schon lange angebahnt
aber kein verantwortlicher ist auf
diesem durch und durch geregelten
staatlich überwachten markt rechtzeitig
aufgebracht um die sache unter kontrolle
zu bringen
und jetzt plötzlich überschlagen sich
die forderungen und schuldzuweisungen
davon werden allerdings die apotheken
regale nicht voll
während benthin berichtet sie haben ihre
medikamente zur zeit nicht lieferbar
also wir haben jetzt alle wiener nicht
apothekerin ines lorenz verwaltet die
täglichen medikamente mangel jeder gelbe
zettel in der schublade heißt nicht
vorhanden nicht lieferbar
das frustriert den im alltag so dermaßen
dass ich jedem zweiten patienten sagen
muss aber nicht kann ich das doch kein
spaß mehr bin ich apotheker geworden um
den leuten zu erklären ich habe ihre
tabletten nicht das problem wächst von
jahr zu jahr 2013 gab es lieferengpässe
bei 42 medikamenten 2018 waren es schon
268 zum teil wichtige heilmittel
im moment sehen zum beispiel
blutdrucksenker lipidsenker also mittel
die den cholesterinwert senken und
schmerzmittel betroffen sind auch einige
psychopharmaka betroffen
und das leider ein zunehmendes phänomen
ein grund der markt der wirkstoff
anbieter hat sich konzentriert die
großproduzenten setzen auf groß fabriken
und das vor allem in niedriglohnländern
fallen hier fabriken aus etwa durch jene
oder sicherheitsmängel bricht gleich
eine große wirkstoffmenge weg bedenklich
aber so funktioniere eben marktdruck
meint die pharmaindustrie eine vielzahl
von arzneimitteln heutzutage von den
herstellern für weniger als einem euro
abgeben
und dieser kostendruck halt dazu geführt
dass eben nach den günstigsten
möglichkeiten geschaut wird wie die
wirkstoffe beschafft werden und dadurch
kommt es leider heute zu verengungen
weil eben wenn ein hersteller ausfällt
dann leider die ware nicht mehr
ausreichend vorhanden ist
der gesundheitsminister will
gegensteuern
er kündigt mehr kontrolle an zur not
auch eine reserve pflicht wollen zum
einen vor allem einen besseren überblick
im ersten schritt auch haben dass es
stärkere meldeverpflichtungen gibt rund
um die lieferengpässe
wir wollen zum zweiten dass unsere
behörden anordnen können da wo sich ein
engpass abzeichnet dass es zu einer
stärkeren auch vorratshaltung kommt bei
den apotheken und vor allem auch den
großhändlern dem koalitionspartner
reicht das noch nicht die spd will
arzneimittelhersteller stärker in die
pflicht nehmen und gegen die niedrig
neuen produktion vorgehen
wir hätten längst schon reagieren müssen
und aus meiner sicht muss jetzt im
wesentlichen zweierlei getan werden wir
müssen für die lieferungen die ausfallen
sanktionen also strafen vereinbaren für
die firmen die nicht liefern können und
zum zweiten für medikamente die kritisch
sind insbesondere für kinder auch für
die krebsbehandlung antibiotika müssen
wir die produktion zurück nach europa
holen
in der lieferung für apothekerin lorenz
fehlen wieder wichtige medikamente
der ärger wächst in deutschland 2009 10
ist es nicht möglich unseren patienten
adäquat zu versorgen
das ist traurig wann genau die
gegenmaßnahmen beschlossen werden ist
offen besser gestern als heute findet in
florenz verständlich die nachrichten
bleiben fürs erste nah am täglichen
leben mit einem bündnis für moderne
mobilität wollen bund länder und
kommunen eine verkehrswende in den
städten erreichen busse und bahnen
radler und fußgänger sollen vorrang
bekommen
bundesverkehrsminister will dabei den
städten mehr entscheidungsspielräume
geben zb beim anwohnerparken dass damit
teurer werden könnte grünen und linken
gehen die ziele des neuen bündnisses für
umweltfreundlichere verkehrslösungen
nicht weit genug
umweltaktivisten forderten einen
günstigeren nahverkehr die festnahme
eines kooperations anwaltes der
deutschen botschaft in ankara wird in
deutschland heftig kritisiert der
präsident des bundesamtes für migration
sommer spricht von einem
außenpolitischen skandal
das auswärtige amt ist mit den behörden
in der türkei in kontakt die deutsche
botschaft mit der familie des anwalts
der türkische anwalt habe bei seiner
festnahme mitte september daten von
asylbewerbern aus der türkei bei sich
gehabt die somit in die hände der
türkischen behörden gelangt sein
betroffene würden informiert in
washington sind die öffentlichen
anhörungen zu einer möglichen
amtsenthebung von us-präsident trump
fortgesetzt worden
dabei positionierte sich die frühere
russland beraterin des weißen hauses
will gegen präsident trump sie wies
dessen theorie zurück die ukraine habe
2016 den us-wahlkampf beeinflusst es sei
unbestritten dass russland systematisch
einfluss auf die wahl genommen habe auch
ein mitarbeiter der us botschaft in kiew
der diplomat holmes belastete trump er
bestätigte den vorwurf trams habe druck
auf die ukraine ausgeübt zum auftakt
seiner asien-reise hat sich papst
franziskus in thailand besorgt über die
weltweite flüchtlingskrise geäußert jede
nation sei aufgefordert migranten zu
schützen
bei einer messe mit rund 60.000
gläubigen in bangkok prangerte der papst
sextourismus und menschenhandel an
frauen und kinder würden zur
prostitution gezwungen und erniedrigt
sexuelle ausbeutung sei eine plage sagte
das oberhaupt der katholischen kirche
zugleich würdigte franziskus die
bemühungen der regierung in thailand
gegen gewalt und missbrauch es ist jetzt
16 jahre her eine ewigkeit da war schon
mal cdu parteitag in leipzig dominiert
von einer oppositionsführerin namens
angela merkel
da wurde das ruder der partei nach
rechts gerissen
ein friedrich merz versprach
steuererklärung auf bierdeckeln drei
steuersätze nur noch alle niedriger als
bisher 12 24 36 prozent eine
krankenversicherung gleich teuer für arm
und reich pauschal und rente erst mit 67
ist alles fast vergessen jetzt cdu
parteitag wieder in leipzig alles andere
anders richtung grün und sozial angela
merkel spricht nur noch ein grußwort ist
nicht mehr die chefin und niemand träumt
mehr von einem erdrutschsieg
es wäre schon ein erfolg wenn die
misserfolge nachließen
hinter alten ritualen steckt dort angst
vor einer letzten abenddämmerung der
volkspartei andreas weise berichtet es
ist ein altbekanntes ritual für annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das erste mal hallen
rundgang mit parteichefin
sie weiß die tage hier in leipzig
könnten für sie durchaus ungemütlich
werden
das ist auch auf diesem parteitag
kontroverse debatten geben wird und
geben kann
das ist vollkommen selbstverständlich
ehrlich gesagt ich freue mich auch
darauf denn der parteitag ist genau der
richtige ort seit knapp einem jahr ist
kramp karrenbauer nun cdu chefin die
bilanz bisher eher durchwachsen zu viele
fettnäpfe und schlechte wahlergebnisse
pflastern ihren weg als der youtuber
rieso zum beispiel die cdu frontal an
geht reagiert die chefin alles andere
als souverän
auch innerparteilich immer wieder
störfeuer zuletzt auf dem deutschlandtag
der jungen union im oktober liebe nun
auf dem parteitag einen antrag auf
urwahl zur kanzlerkandidatur einbringen
einer frau gegen die parteivorsitzende
bei den parteigranden die sich heute
schon in leipzig trafen findet das
allerdings wenig unterstützung
wir haben erfahrung mit urwahl gemacht
ich habe heute gelesen baden württemberg
das ähnliche erfahrungen gemacht hat hat
ähnliche skepsis
wir sehen die spd seit sechs wochen in
der selbstbeschäftigung und mir ist vor
allem wichtig eine entscheidung in der
kanzlerkandidatur muss zwischen cdu und
csu gemeinsam fallen nicht zurück nach
vorne will die parteispitze in leipzig
schauen ein wunsch der an der basis wie
hier in griesheim bei darmstadt durchaus
auch da ist aber einfach weiter so das
wollen viele nicht im regierungsprogramm
in der koalitionsvertrag findet man
nicht immer wieder harte cdu-forderung
das hat zu einer gewissen
unzufriedenheit auch mitgliedern geführt
so dass die jetzt versuchen diese
unzufriedenheit in bahnen zu lenken
leider sind personaldebatten die
einfachsten debatten immer führen kann
zum großen showdown um die
kanzlerkandidatur kramp karrenbauer oder
friedrich merz die es noch vor kurzem
möglich schien wird es wohl nicht kommen
im vorfeld des parteitages spürbar das
verlangen nicht als zerstrittener haufen
dazustehen
für mich ist das eigentlich ein
positives zeichen dass wir cdu
wir christdemokraten köpfe haben und es
wird um keine kanzlerfrage gehen es wird
auch um keine vorsitzenden frage gehen
sonst um sachfragen gehen nach einem
jahr an der spitze der cdu ist annegret
kramp karrenbauer nicht unumstritten und
zuallererst verantwortlich für das
schicksal der partei guten abend v kam
kam bauer
hallo genannte gebe die zahlen der
wahlen und der umfragen sind eindeutig
sie persönlich und die partei sind in
einen abwärtssog wie soll ein parteitag
sowas stoppen wenn sie erst einmal damit
dass wir uns mit politik beschäftigen zu
den themen die den menschen auf den
nägeln brennen frage sozialer
marktwirtschaft frage was bringt die
digitalisierung wie gleichen wir moderne
landwirtschaftspolitik mit umweltschutz
aus all das diskutieren wir darauf geben
wir antworten das ist das was die
bürgerinnen bürger von uns erwarten
sie schieben die sachthemen nach vorne
gleichzeitig muss man sagen dass die
wichtigsten entscheidungen der letzten
zeit von der flüchtlingspolitik über die
abschaffung der wehrpflicht den
doppelpass und so weiter
immer ohne oder gegen
parteitagsbeschlüsse entstanden sind und
die kanzlerin sagt jetzt schon oder
lässt erkennen wenn huawei
der chinesische internet anbieter oder
telefonie anbieter gesperrt wird dann
wird sie sich darum nicht scheren
warum sollen dann parteitagsbeschlüsse
die verhältnisse ändern also zum ersten
muss man ganz deutlich sagen dass in der
vergangenheit zu recht in der cdu
kritisiert worden ist dass wir
entscheidungen herbeigeführt haben durch
regierungshandeln nicht ausdiskutiert in
der partei ich bin extra angetreten um
das zu ändern zum zweiten werden wir
morgen eine beschlussfassung zu hohe
welle haben die aus meiner sicht den
sicherheitsinteressen sehr gut entgegen
kommt sie sehr gut ab spiegelt und die
eine vertretbare grundlage auch für
gutes regierungshandeln ist unsere
reporter die die cdu beobachten sagen
dass überall wo sehen kommen über
personen gesprochen wird nicht zu sehr
über sachfragen
sie wollen die personen fragen in
leipzig draußen halten wie soll das denn
funktionieren
ich habe der partei einen vorschlag
gemacht wie die entsprechenden personen
fragen es geht ja konkret um die
kanzlerkandidatur geklärt werden sollen
nämlich auf dem parteitag 2020 das ist
der parteitag wo es auch hingehört bis
dahin müssen wir die cdu inhaltlich
organisatorisch auch in der personellen
verbreiterung so aufstellen dass wir mit
erfolg wahlen schmal kämpfe bestreiten
können wahlen gewinnen können denn das
ist die grundvoraussetzung für
kanzlerkandidatur in den kanzler
schafften nach ihnen auf dem parteitag
wird ein delegierter aus dem
hochsauerland sprechen namens friedrich
merz sie sagen das ist ein kluger kopf
aber spüren schon auch denke ich dass er
ein konkurrent ist oder er ist ein
kluger kopf ist jemand der die partei
bereich hat deswegen freue ich mich dass
er in der aussprache sich zu wort melden
wird das air vorstellungen ideen
einbringen wird denn der parteitag ist
genau der ort um darüber zu sprechen
darüber auch befinden zu lassen
diskutieren zu lassen
das wird nicht mehr fried geschmerzt tun
das werden viele andere auch tun
und wenn am ende das ergebnis ist eine
weiterentwicklung unserer partei hinter
der sich alle versammeln können dann ist
das gut und dann habe ich meine aufgabe
als parteivorsitzender auch gut gemacht
meine frage war ob sie schon spüren dass
er auch ein konkurrent ist er ist vor
allen dingen jemand den ich schätze mit
dem ich nach wie vor ein gutes
verhältnis habe und von dem ich mich
immer freue wenn er die partei
konstruktiv mit begleitet und nach vorne
bringt also kein konkurrent sie können
noch zweimal nachfragen ich habe in
meiner antwort gegeben und ich glaube
dies hinreichend konkret in der cdu gibt
es ja eine schöne tradition die ich es
immer der parteivorsitzende in diesem
fall die parteivorsitzende hat den
ersten zugriff wenn es um die
kanzlerkandidatur geht soll sich das
unter ihnen ändern oder aufweichen
ich habe ganz deutlich gesagt die
parteivorsitzende ich werde das prinzip
werde dieses verfahren von vorne führen
endpunkt zielpunkt ist der parteitag
2020 aber das ist eine debatte die wir
dann führen müssen aus meiner sicht und
nicht heute
heute geht es darum vertrauen des
verloren gegangen
ist in die cdu aber vertrauen dass
verloren gegangen ist in das
regierungshandeln dadurch
zurückzugewinnen
dass wir uns eben nicht mit uns selbst
beschäftigen sondern mit den themen die
die menschen interessieren ich habe sie
eben genannt und dass wir der gegenstand
der nächsten anderthalb tage sein
jetzt habe ich noch nicht verstanden was
der unterschied ist zwischen von vorne
führen und erster zugriff haben
das werden sie dann auf dem parteitag
2020 sehen sind sie sicher dass es da
einen unterschied gibt auch das werden
sie dann sehen ich stehe in diesem
prozess das habe ich angekündigt als ich
mich um den parteivorsitz beworben habe
diesen prozess diese aufgabe nehme ich
sehr sehr ernst aber wie gesagt der
erste schritt ist die cdu auch
inhaltlich so attraktiv zu machen dass
sie mehrheiten gewinnen kann das ist die
grundvoraussetzung für alles andere in
der tat frage noch haben sie in sich
selbst stand heute zweifel ob sie
kanzlerin können ich habe in mir selbst
vor allen dingen den wunsch und die
feste entschlossenheit dass das morgen
und übermorgen ein guter parteitag wird
von dem alle nach hause gehen und sagen
wir sind ein stück weiter gekommen wir
sind geschlossen wir sind ein gutes
angebot an die menschen in deutschland
und geben uns damit einen maßstab für
den sonntag dankeschön
dieses interview haben wir so etwa um 18
uhr genauso geführt nachrichten aus der
wirtschaft das endgültige aus für den
reiseveranstalter thomas cook in
deutschland treibt mitarbeiter und
kunden um
der vorstand des insolventen
unternehmens bestätigte heute die
zerschlagung
so werden zb neckermann reisen kommende
woche eingestellt frank bethmann
was bedeutet das für kunden die ihre
gebuchten reisen bereits bezahlt haben
die werden vermutlich nur einen teil
ihrer anzahlung oder ihres buchungs
preises wiedersehen denn die
schadensumme übersteigt deutlich den
haftungsrahmen aber erst der anwälte
bringen sich in stellung wollen das so
nicht akzeptieren sie sehen beim
deutschen staat eine mitschuld denn der
habe geltendes europäisches recht nicht
konsequent umgesetzt die eu
versicherungs richtlinie verpflichtet
die mitgliedsstaaten nämlich dazu
pauschalreisenden im falle einer
insolvenz eines veranstalters
vollumfänglichen schutz zu bieten den
gibt es so in deutschland bislang nicht
sollten auch die richter darin ein
versäumnis sehen könnten sich die
betroffenen feriengäste den rest ihres
geldes wohl beim finanzminister
zurückholen
derweil zeichnet sich ein happy end für
rund 1000 mitarbeiter der deutschen
thomas cook tochter ab ihre
beschäftigung scheint gesichert
so übernimmt der warenhauskonzern
karstadt kaufhof ein großteil der
reisebüros und erhält in dem bereich 500
arbeitsplätze auch die rund 90 jobs
bürgertums bleiben erhalten sie
übernimmt der reiseveranstalter an ex
tour berechtigte hoffnungen können sich
auch die mitarbeiter machen die für die
hotelkette sind tito für die bekannte
marke neckermann reisen und für das call
center in bochum arbeiten für mehrere
hundert weitere beschäftigte bleibt nach
der heutigen entscheidung aber wohl nur
noch der weg zum arbeitsamt
vielen dank für diese information franke
jahre lang war sie eine der größten
brücken baustelle europas heute wurde
die hochmoselbrücke für den verkehr
freigegeben
die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in dreier eröffnete
die verkehrsader über das moseltal
deutschlands zweithöchster brücke soll
die benelux-staaten und das rhein main
gebiet besser verbinden
das bauwerk ist umstritten gegner sehen
eine entzauberung der natur landschaft
und kritisieren die kosten für das
gesamte projekt von fast einer halben
milliarde euro und eine meldung vom
sport die deutschen tennis herren haben
in der endrunde des davis cups vorzeitig
das viertelfinale erreicht
im gruppenspiel gegen chile gewann
philipp kohlschreiber die partie gegen
nicholas carr mit 6 4 und 6 3
damit sicherte der 36 jährige dem
deutschen team den benötigten punkt für
den gruppensieg und den einzug in die
ko-runde
dort trifft deutschland morgen auf
großbritannien als die welt noch groß
war also ein forscher aus preußen noch
regionen erkunden und berge besteigen
konnte die kein weißer mensch zuvor
gesehen hatte hat alexander von humboldt
die welt vermessen etwa den chimborazo
in ecuador mit seinen über
6000 metern humboldts geschichte ist
eine von wissbegier mut und
entdeckerdrang sein bruder wilhelm
errichtete derweil im preußen ein
bildungssystem im geist der aufklärung
zwei lichtgestalten der deutschen
geschichte
das aktuelle deutschland hat dann das
riesige neue humboldt forum in der mitte
berlins zum 250 geburtstag von alexander
humboldt nicht rechtzeitig fertig
bekommen aber berlin fand einen platz
vereine nicht mehr ganz unkritische
ausstellung über leben und werk der
beiden deutschen idole stephan
merseburger berichtet die brüder
humboldt alexander superstar abenteurer
weltbürger der letzte universalgelehrte
wilhelm diplomat und bildungsreformer
schöpfer des gymnasiums und der
universität den preußischen berlin
so weit so bekannt die berliner
ausstellung im deutschen historischen
museum schaut sich die beiden so hoch
gerühmten lichtgestalten etwas genauer
an
es geht uns überhaupt nicht gegen etwas
zu arbeiten sondern für etwas und dass
dieses für ist eine bessere historische
verankerung von zwei figuren die es sich
lohnt zu kennen
aber wo er den eindruck hatten dass sie
in dieser stadt in berlin sehr zu
etiketten verkommen sind es sind söhne
aus reichem adligem hause von den besten
privatlehrern im sinne der aufklärung
unterrichtet als junge männer erhalten
sie zugang zum elitären salon von
henriette herz juden und
schriftstellerin amouröse eskapaden
revolutionäre freiheiten offene
beziehungen
das war für die die geburt der gefühle
die vielleicht die aktivierung der
neurone in einem sehr schnellen
konkurrenzverhalten denn diese frauen
waren sehr schnell sehr schlau und man
musste mithalten
mit seiner frau caroline lebt wilhelm 40
jahre in offener er zunächst befürwortet
er die emanzipation der juden später
äußerte sich antisemitisch über eine
frühere freundin die einen angehenden
preußischen diplomaten heiratet so kann
sie noch einmal eine gesandten frau und
exzellenz werden es ist nichts was der
juden nicht erreicht alexander ist
naturwissenschaftler
umweltschützer und fürsprecher der
indigenen völker aber auf seiner
südamerika reise wird er zum grabräuber
und schreibt armes volk selbst in den
gräbern stört man seine ruhe
da merkt man wie die wissenschaft der
jahre um 1800 und danach dieser waren
alles versammeln zu müssen um das
studieren zu können
die rassenkunde die sich dann entwickelt
zum rassismus das hat hier seinen anfang
und er ist eine der vielen die eben
damit machen die humboldts waren
fortschrittlich große denker kinder
ihrer zeit die auch von kolonialismus
nationalismus und antisemitismus geprägt
waren
lichtgestalten sicher doch wo licht ist
ist auch schatten
maybrit illners runde widmet sich einem
der verborgenen skandale in diesem land
dass der lebensweg der kinder immer noch
viel zu stark davon abhängt wie viel
geld und bildung die eltern haben obwohl
jedes jahr 200 milliarden euro für die
förderung der familien ausgegeben werden
darüber muss man reden passiert gleich
und wir sagen bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
winterlich kalt mit dauerfrost auch
tagsüber ist es europaweit gesehen
eigentlich nur in russland mit minus 5
grad sonst liegen die temperaturen oft
bei 5 bis 15 grad ob nun im baltikum am
bosporus oder auch in galicien und das
ist eine besonders spannende region denn
da kommt ein neues tieferen tiefs louis
und das bringt morgen orkanböen an der
atlantikküste portugals und spaniens
schnee ist nicht in sicht es sei denn es
gibt erzogene hebung also wenn sich
berge den wolken in den weg stellen wir
hier zum beispiel den pyrenäen oder auch
in den alpen kein schnee fällt bei uns
heute nach der fällt höchstens etwas
regen im nordosten viel gefährlicher ist
aber der regen der von frankreich heran
kommt denn der fällt zum beispiel in der
eifel oder im hunsrück auf den
gefrorenen boden aber dass spiegelglatt
denn etwa südlich der nördlichen
mittelgebirge sinken die temperaturen
auf +2 bis -3 grad dort reicht also
überall für bodenfrost im nordosten
unter den regenwolken bleibt es milder
und bilder für uns alle wird es morgen
über tag meist sind es sieben bis zwölf
grad selten bleibt es mal ein bisschen
kühler wenn sich nebel und hochnebel
länger halten aber in norddeutschland
sollte sich häufiger die sonne zeigen
können weil süd wird
einzig im emsland und am niederrhein
kann es vor allen dingen am vormittag
leicht regnen
in der mitte ist es trüb ganz im süden
zeigt sich dagegen häufiger die sonne
und mit diesem ruhigen spätherbst wetter
geht es auch am wochenende weiter
schönen abend noch